good morning John I love it a small town
in Montana where I have several times
been asked if I'm interested in running
for local election as a local business
owner and a semi celebrity and a person
who was very good at picking karaoke
songs I would have an okay chance of
winning but what pops into my mind every
time somebody asked me this question is
that I'm not really from Missoula
Montana
I'm from the internet now that raises
some interesting questions about like
the concept of place and the future of
local government and the future of the
autonomy of the internet but those are
big abstract questions the more pressing
one is if Internet citizenship exists
then are there some things that we could
be doing to be better internet citizens
I think yes and here's my first crack at
some guidelines
people on the Internet are people the
Internet is real life treat people like
people online or off every person is
complicated and impossible to fully
understand if you think you've got
somebody pegged completely after reading
a twenty five word comment you're wrong
removing comments and communities that
dehumanize or mock other people is not
censorship
it's kindness everybody can see and read
the stuff that you put on the internet
and it will probably be there pretty
much forever so be thoughtful be s
detection is one of the most crucial
skills of the online citizen it takes a
long time to develop that set of skills
in fact it's something that I think
should be taught in schools everywhere
number one rule though cite your sources
and don't share statistics that you
can't find sources for just because
something seems like it's true does not
mean it is and then general don't share
things that might be lies even if they
help you make a point that is really
important to make mark twain said it
best of course a lie can travel halfway
around the world while the truth is
putting on its shoes don't be part of
the problem help the truth put its shoes
on you don't know everything nobody does
nobody even knows most things don't
steal stuff from creators and then
repost it without attribution do however
attempt to source unsourced content by
using reverse image search engines like
10i not only is this good internet
citizenship it's also a great way to
hone your research skills anyone can
edit Wikipedia for real if you see a
grammatical or spelling mistake go ahead
and fix it if you find a vandalized page
you can fix that by going to the page
history finding the change that
introduced the vandalism and then click
do it's that simple if you'd like to do
more than just fix small errors and
vandalism on Wikipedia articles you can
read more about the philosophy and
strategies of the series Wikipedia
editor before you start to actually make
big changes and in general if you're
joining any new online community of
people doing something together or
enjoying something together recognize
that they're probably going to be some
rules that you do not yet know and that
you're probably gonna make some early
mistakes if you are part of one of those
existing communities and new people come
in expect that they're not going to know
all the rules and they are gonna make
some mistakes and finally don't expect
that everyone or even you is going to be
able to follow all of these rules all of
the time sometimes we get angry
sometimes we all act like jerks the
understanding of yourself and be
understanding of others when I asked
Twitter and Tumblr with the most
important rules of internet citizenship
where a lot of people pointed me towards
law which I like but it's a little bit
subjective reworded slightly for the
families out there Wheaton's law is
basically just don't be a jerk the
response I like the most went further
than that
always leave people in places better
than the way that you found them that's
what we should be working for in this
wonderful place that has in many ways
become my home John I'll see you on
Tuesday the second episode of dear Hank
and John our new podcast is out and
online now we're gonna try and have one
every single week coming out like Sunday
and Monday is sheeples seem to be liking
it here's some tweets that we didn't
even solicit Jim Hanken John is such a
funny awesome podcast laughing silently
on the bus dear Hank and John it's gold
Peggy John's podcast may be the greatest
thing ever commutes just got a whole lot
better new podcast and cereal time have
been the highlights of my June I really
don't see it getting any better than
this thank you which brings up the fact
that cereal time has been going now for
a week a little more than a week and I
love it also Titans grave is still
happening and it's so funny I love it I
mean it's just me I like it's me being a
dork with my dork friends but it's great
you can find links to how to get to view
hanga John and all those other things in
the description below thanks for
watching
dftba